[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice i'm
dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us open phones at
825-5225 it's a free call and some say
the advice is worth exactly what you pay
for it we're glad you're with us america
triple eight eight two five five two two
five esmeralda starts off this hour in
jacksonville florida hi esmerelda how
are you hi good dave how are you better
than i deserve what's up
hi so
i'm in a brand new relationship
we are in the getting to know you phase
but i'm already very fond of this man
and i care very much about
him and his young girls
um i've told him i'm following the baby
steps
but
he's heard good things he's not familiar
and he's currently playing
the zero percent credit card game
now i have thoughts out like i could
just go up i have been restraining
myself okay
and i'm just asking for
your guidance on
how do i coach or guide him in a gentle
way to not step on the toes of this
brand new relationship but also start to
try to
teach him about what's helped me and i'm
on babysit four
yeah
uh you don't talk to him about his stuff
you talk to him about your stuff
let's tell your story just tell your
story a lot and it is um it's your story
and you know my story was that i did
this and this and this and it didn't
work and i used to screw around with
credit cards all the time and they
didn't end up being a blessing to me and
i decided that what i wanted was the
peaceful
easy feeling to quote the eagles right
of uh being debt-free right i i you know
i just i and so i've been working to get
out of that and you know i told you a
little bit about that and and i got to
tell you it's something that's kind of
central to what i'm doing right now and
i'm really excited about it and so means
a lot to me
and i'm getting out of debt and and the
feeling is amazing the empowerment that
i've got is amazing and just tell your
story if that isn't your story then
change it and make it your story but i
mean i was just trying to superimpose my
my verbage over you in that situation
you follow me
yes sir that and that is my story and
i want it's like i want that form too
but you're right okay i'll focus on me
he'll he'll come around he'll come
around
and you know there's other things in the
relationship that you're gonna get have
serious discussions about
as the relationship goes through its
various phases i mean you're gonna have
a lot of discussions if you're smart
about parenting and about what being
in those little girls life means if
you're going to be there
what role you're going to play you know
you're going to want to find out um
that that uh
if um if one of them tattles on you if
you're in trouble
meaning that if meaning that they they
hold too high a seat in the household in
the event you're there
um you know you're gonna wanna you're
gonna get that positioning straightened
out at some point agreed
and i've got one of my own oh well there
you go and how are we going to how are
we going to do the brady bunch you know
you do the mix here right you know
that's a complicated it's a complicated
process and so those discussions are
very serious and very
heartfelt and um mean a lot to both of
you and so does the discussion around
money and so does the discussion around
religion and so does the discussion
around in-laws that are crazy and what
are we going to do with them
and you know because everybody's got one
and you know what what's the discussion
so
it's kids money in-laws and religion are
the four big things that break marriages
up
and if you can have good solid in-depth
discussions prior to marriage about all
four and be on the same page about all
four you have a very high statistical
probability of winning with with your
marriage
and money's just one of them
you know so that that's good you know
you so you just as this as but no more
would you get involved in
a deep parenting discussion than you
would a deep money discussion at
at the early stages of a relationship
but somewhere up in there when things
are getting serious you definitely will
right
yes yes
yeah yeah at some point you are going to
have to throw out there you know you're
a little further down the road probably
but
this means so much to me that it's like
a deal breaker if we can't be on the
same page about money
and it would be because i can't
i can't go back
i don't want him to struggle either
because i care too much you know no it's
not yeah i i don't want to attach myself
to a sinking ship
that too yeah you've done that before
and i won't do that again
and um even if it's a really pretty
attractive sinking ship
[Laughter]
fair enough
fair enough thanks steve have fun kiddo
we appreciate you calling in erica is
with us in sacramento hey erica welcome
to the ramsay show
hi dave
so um i have a what would dave do
question um we decided to finally start
the baby steps and
we have 31 000 saved up right now that
we were planning on putting it towards
our thirty two thousand dollars in
credit card debt
but we found out that my husband um is
going to be switching over vehicles for
work um two years ago we bought a truck
for forty two thousand dollars that his
company has been making the payment
every month and paying for gas and
mileage but in four months they are
going to give him a
new truck and they're going to be
responsible for paying his gas mileage
insurance wear and tear wonderful um we
yeah we owe 20 000 on that truck so in
four months we're going to be
responsible for that you have been
responsible for it all along
yeah i just gave you the money for your
responsibility
exactly
so my
i
the way i see it i have three options we
have three options um i can we can save
up five thousand dollars a month for the
next
four months
pay the truck off
or
we can sell the truck and make about
three thousand dollars
because i have a small little beater car
that i drive for three thousand
but it needs about two thousand dollars
worth of work
um what would you do would you sell the
truck pay off the truck
both of them and buy you an eight
thousand dollar car
okay
and he's got a trucks they're giving him
yes yeah that's what i do yeah for sure
and you got almost enough money between
your car and his truck to do that you'd
only put 2 000 out of 31 towards it
three and three three out of yours three
above on his truck right
yes and and two out of your savings and
we got an eight thousand dollar car for
you that's a dead gum serious move up
for you
because you're driving you're driving
crap you know and we get rid of his 20
000 truck
and
he drives the company truck right
yes i love it
all right sounds good that work for you
it does um yeah we just we still have a
um
ninety thousand dollar heloc and a
ninety thousand dollar mortgage so yeah
well you're going to attract that heat
lock now with the 29 000 that's left
over out of the 31 right
[Music]
yes and and now you just get roll up
your sleeves and get after it do that
budget thing that gazelle intense thing
that uh you know we're not gonna see the
inside of a restaurant unless we're
working their thing because we're
getting out of debt
we're doing this
that's how you decide
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five
two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money this is
the ramsay show where common sense shows
up for your life your work your money
your relationships david is in houston
texas hi david welcome to the ramsey
show
thank you very much i'm dave i
appreciate you taking my call sure
what's up i'll be pro i'll i'll be brief
here's my question my wife and i have
really worked hard over the past two
years working on paying off our mortgage
good
we've got 60 000 left on our mortgage
wow you're almost there
all right i'm i'm now 59 and a half and
i've got 1.9 by 401k
should i take the money out and be done
with this and pay it off or keep
plugging along
on my mortgage look at you
congratulations millionaire
thank you how much of this did you
inherit
zero
well
hang on a minute my grandmother left me
a uh
50
uh savings bond so
that probably helped me out
you know what probably helped you out
was her character in in your dna i like
it
that's awesome
so uh
oh man
uh what's your household income sir
um 260. cool what's the house worth
uh about 500. okay
well there's certainly nothing wrong
with cashing enough out today
mathematically to pay off your house
instantaneously you're debt free
okay would you say the house is worth
500 okay all right cool
all right so you're worth over two
million dollars net worth we know that
so you could do that and it would would
be blank however you make enough money
to knock sixty thousand dollars out real
fast
and allow that money to lay in there and
continue to grow tax deferred or tax
free
so i'd be tempted to not let the
government get their hands on the money
if it was me
uh just because you can do it within a
year right
well the gold is uh
july yeah
so i mean for the difference in the
taxes that you would pay by pulling the
money out of the 401k there's no penalty
because you're 59.5 but the taxes i just
go ahead and use my income to do it i'm
already paying taxes on it and let's be
done by july
just for that reason but there's no
wrong answer here it's just that's an
idea
yeah that's what my wife wants to do uh
and but i kind of wanted to be done with
it start 2022 with fresh
with with zero debt yeah i said i'll
call dave and see what he's saying
i i'm gonna i'm gonna go with your wife
because the taxes on the 60 grand are
going to be 20 grand in your world
and you don't need the money out of the
401k you're not going to be touching it
anyway
you have mandatory withdrawals if it's
traditional that begin at 70 and a half
right but until then you could let that
money grow and instead of giving that 20
000 to the government now
wait 10 20 years to give it to the
government
so i i i'm with you emotionally i'd like
to be done right now because i'm going
to rip the band-aid off guy but uh but
mathematically cost you extra 20 grand
this year
to do it this year unless you do it out
of your income and you'll be done by
july anyway if it met six years instead
of six months i do it in a heartbeat
but it's six months it's all in the same
tax year even
so yeah i'm sorry i'm going with your
wife on this one but it's let me just
tell you again neither one of these
boxes are in the stupid column you can
check either one of them and they're
both in the smart column you guys have
been amazing your heroes your
everyday baby steps millionaires you've
done the stuff we talk about well done
i'm proud of you all right denise is in
indianapolis hi denise how are you
i am well
i have a quick question as well uh i
have an annuity that i cannot access
i can't roll it into an ira it was
given to me through a divorce
i have the option of beginning to draw
monthly payments as early as age 60.
my question is should i treat this as i
would with social security and begin the
draw as soon as it is available and
reinvest it into mutual funds or should
i wait and let it continue to grow
it'll grow faster if you pull it and
invest it it'll grow faster if you pull
and invest it so are you sure you can't
take a lump sum on this and roll it
uh i actually worked with a smart
investor pro and he said no we can't do
that
okay
because i would think you could move
this to a variable annuity from it's a
fixed annuity right
but is it because of the divorce
settlement uh
documentation or is it
just the type of product it is
i think it's the type of product
okay well there's a thing called a
variable annuity that's mutual funds
inside of an annuity and you can move
from annuity to annuity pretty easily
uh
unless you've got severe how long have
you had this other annuity
uh about five years yeah you might have
a seven years worth of
uh surrender charges in it and that may
be what he's looking at or she's looking
at this saying don't take those
surrender charges
circle back with that smart visitor pro
again and ask him about moving it to a
variable annuity and why that doesn't
work
they may be right but i want to
understand why if i'm you so rule you
know my first choice would be moving to
a variable annuity and get the whole
thing in mutual funds inside of a
variable annuity my second choice would
be to take it as quickly as you can like
you said like social security early and
just start moving it
monthly systematically over to
good mutual funds that way so good
question thank you for joining us
one week from today thursday january the
13th is our free
free free free free free live stream
event
called building wealth in 2022.
the in-person tickets have been sold out
for a couple of weeks over 1500 folks
are going to join us in the live
audience
over 60 000 are already registered for
the live stream we're thinking we're
gonna have over a hundred thousand join
us for that on thursday january the 13th
it's a big deal building wealth in 2022
rachel cruz george campbell ramsey
personalities best-selling authors will
be with me to talk about how to build
wealth this year we're not only going to
talk about what's going on out there in
the real world uh stuff like uh nothing
down real estate that's happening nfts
are happening uh man i'm telling you
there's a bitcoin is happening there's a
lot of things going on out there in the
world and uh you know what is the best
way in 2022 for you to build wealth and
why and let's talk about this sanely
without all the emotion and all the name
calling and all that we're going to just
show you what it really is we're going
to unpack so you really know what to do
you got to tune in join us exactly one
week from today building wealth 2022 it
is a free
live stream
january the 13th
if you want to watch it you do have to
pre-register to watch it it is free
though go to ramsey solutions dot com
slash wealth ramsey solutions dot com
slash wealth our question today comes
from blinds.com find out for yourself
why blinds.com is the number number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings free samples free shipping and
new promos every month great american
company blinds.com always use the promo
code ramsey
josh is in georgia my brother is getting
married next year he asked me to be in
the wedding party as a groomsman very
nice he's having a destination wedding
five hours away
and going would cause me to sacrifice
ten thousand dollars in lost wages one
three thousand dollars for a hotel
driving expenses food etc for me and my
family i want to go and show my support
but i don't think it's feasible to lose
that much money for a wedding while i'm
still in debt
with a mortgage and a car payment
should i be part of the wedding or tell
him i can't afford it
uh
josh you're exaggerating
you're gonna go for a wedding and you're
gonna lose ten thousand dollars in lost
wages i'm calling bs
three thousand dollars for a hotel
or the flip is this
i'm calling bs
so maybe you just fly in just in time
for the wedding and stay one night and
you fly right back out and you were
there for your brother's wedding but you
couldn't do all of the week-long party
that's probably what i'm doing
yeah
you're exaggerating because you don't
like that he's doing this and forcing it
on you
i think you can do this very very
inexpensively and it's your brother and
you probably should
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you for joining us america this is
the ramsey show we talk about your life
your work
your money your relationships we're glad
you're here triple eight eight 825-5225
morgan is in atlanta georgia hi morgan
welcome to the show
hi thank you
um
my husband and i both work in a volatile
industry we were introduced to your
principals about 18 months ago and
immediately went into store mode
since then we've saved 50 000 and i
started a second career
unfortunately we found ourselves feeling
dave ish wavering in and out of
emergency mode as we found success with
my second career using that to pay off
some debt refinance our house cash flow
emergencies and do some home
improvements we still have
65 000 in debt though and i'm wondering
you know can we continue on this path
using my second career um to to finish
paying off the debt
uh and preserve our 50k we've saved or
is it time to just decide you know
you're either in store mode or you're
not and
how do you do home repairs when you're
in a snow storm home renovations when
you're in storm mode
that's illogical
my second
income my second question but you're in
storm mode
you're too scared to pay it on the debt
but you're not too scared to fix your
kitchen up
i'm i think i'm more scared to not have
money i haven't i still have two careers
you fixed up your kitchen
no i didn't i i didn't
well what was the home renovation
well it was a home improvement it was a
retaining wall
okay so why couldn't that wait if you're
in storm mode
that's why i'm calling yeah my point is
is that you're picking and choosing when
you decide you want to be afraid or not
i don't want to be afraid when i'm
talking about my income from the new
career i don't want to be afraid when
i'm talking about doing something i want
to do which is a retaining wall
but when i want to pay off debt now i
want to be afraid
i guess i'm i'm afraid i'm going to use
that savings and then i'm going to lose
you used it for a retaining wall
that's my second job and it's it's um
it's all your income
it's all your income it's all one pile
there's no bifurcation here
okay
you're not getting it you are really
inconsistent in this
and so you got to decide what you is
you got to decide are you going to keep
running this plan or are you going to
say
all right
this storm mode thing is not real or it
is real if it is real it means you don't
need to do any
thing with any
money
except pile it up
that's storm mode okay we think we're
going to lose our jobs our careers are
volatile and we're going to be on the
street homeless and we just need to stop
and know no retaining walls
no vacations
no eating out
we're afraid we're going to lose our
income
so we're not willing to work a plan
until we can get stabilized we are
pushing pause on any progress of any
kind anywhere in our life and piling up
cash getting ready for a nuclear winter
that's storm mode
if you're not that scared
then you need to cash all this thinking
money out and quit screwing around and
get out of that
how do we know when we're in a volatile
industry how do you know when
how do you feel good about exiting storm
mode
well there's okay there's two kinds of
fear here
how long have you been doing this
volatile industry
my entire career
for how many years
um
15
and how many times have you been without
income
zero
okay so
the volatile industry thing is a
mythology
i hope so no honey it's 15 years and
you've made money every year
it you know you you're just afraid of
the fact it goes up and down
but the actual facts are disputing your
feelings
okay
aren't they what am i missing
um
i i don't know i just am not confident
in my career i mean this is the least
confident i've ever been what do you do
i'm an airline pilot
okay all right
uh well today they could use your help
they can but they also could determine
that
because i've chosen medical freedom yeah
i understand that you've got to be put
on the street
you can be put on the street okay
so until the storm passes you don't need
to do anything else or until you get
your income up
in another area which means the storm
has passed you don't need to do anything
else
and so um
i don't disagree with your conclusions
or your stance or anything else it's not
the point uh but
for 15 years the airline
pilots have not been volatile i mean
it's the er the income is irregular
based on how much you work or don't work
but the chances of you being completely
out of work for the last 15 years is is
higher at this moment than it has ever
been based on your choices
but i mean airline pilot so what
okay
the the other thing is is that you are
an airline pilot now what that means is
that you prepare
for your job every day against only and
or mostly against worst case scenarios
right everything you do is to avoid a
crash
it is in your it's in your nature thank
god because that's what you're good at
right i mean i don't really want you
flying unless you do that okay so i'm
not it's not a criticism but the very
the very essence of your job is to
constantly prepare for worst case
scenarios
it's safety thank you exactly exactly
but that that translates then in your it
gets into your nervous system and that
translates over to your checkbook
and you go okay i'm gonna run my
finances the way i fly the airplane i'm
gonna only prepare for worst case
scenarios and i'm gonna pretend like
we're about to crash at any moment and
i've really got to have thought through
every checklist i've got to talk every
backup switch i got to throw
every scenario right and because that's
what you guys do i mean you're really
good at it thank god that's why we have
very few airline crashes so um
you know you guys your profession is
amazing
but but the the essence of your
profession doesn't help your nervous
system
adjust to your finances your finances
are a lot safer
than
you you shouldn't run your finances like
you fly an airplane that's what i'm
trying to say
okay that makes sense
it does so you guys have a lot of money
you've done very well you're going to be
okay
how much notice do you think you'll get
you're not going to get put on the
street in 24 hours
you're probably going to get you're
probably going to get six months or
90 days anyway notice on uh
on vaccine right
uh yeah it'll take two to three months
yeah okay
if that actually happens let's worry
about it then
okay
in the mean in the meantime because let
me just say this way okay let's pretend
that that you had no money
because you put it all on the debt when
you get off the phone here
this is a great conversation by the way
thank you for calling hello terrifying
i love it i love it well i mean i'm
messing with you because but it's really
a good conversation so let's pretend you
got you had put all the money today on
the debt
and you had no cash except a thousand
dollars because you're working the baby
steps pure
okay
how much debt have you got
about 65k
oh my god you're almost debt free when
we write this check then okay
uh but let's pretend you're not that
that you got 15 000 in debt
because we wrote 50 towards it today
and you got the call tomorrow right
after you wrote those checks and the
money was already out the door
that you got 60 days
if you didn't do anything
at all for 60 days except pile up cash
you'd have a really big pile of cash in
60 days wouldn't you
we could come up with some yeah yeah i'm
talking about you do nothing no
retaining walls no going out to eat no
nothing and you use all three sources of
income and you just do nothing
and you pile up cash because it's an
emergency
you'll be okay you guys you're in good
shape i'd write a check today and i'd be
moving towards debt freedom i think
you're going to be debt free and i think
it's going to change your whole
vision on your second career and on how
you react to those first careers demands
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you for joining us america this is
the ramsey show we're so glad you're
with us
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five
two two five
[Music]
in america for the last 24 months
lots of people have lived in such a
jacked up
anxiety ridden
semi-rage
state of mind
that to come back down off of all of
those hormones and proteins
and be calm again is kind of a weird
thing
might be a good new year's resolution by
the way
turn off the television
the news channels anyway
uh unplug or largely unplug from social
media
and back away from the manure
if you're pouring that much manure into
your brain your brain is going to turn
into manure
i knew i had a problem when i actually
violated one of my lifelong rules one of
my rules is don't ever read the comments
after any article
if you want to know why some species eat
their young you can tell
by reading the comments after the
articles these are some of the dumbest
human beings on the planet
and some of the meanest too
any article on anything
i i knew it was time for me to just
back away
from the screen
because you get in jacked up mode
because here's the thing dr dolony talks
about this all the time facts are your
friends
and when your brain is jacked up like
that
on fear
and rage
you've been doing all the covet fear
porn over and over death you're going to
die you're going to die you're going to
die you're going to die
and your brain gets jacked up
to the point that your critical thinking
skills just disappear
none of us
do good critical long-term thinking
when we were really angry or really
afraid
your brain doesn't work that way
if you're standing near the street and a
car at 60 miles an hour swerves towards
you
your brain is designed to scream at you
get out of the way
not to analyze the possible impact of a
2019 escalade on my hip
you don't have time to do all of these
discussions in your head just move
your brain is primitive and is designed
to throw you out of the way
of danger not to have a critical
thinking discussion about it
or what i should have said in that
argument
get out of the way and so your brain
shuts down its ability to do critical
thinking when you're freaked out
and when you're in trauma like that the
lonely teaches us and it's been a really
good lesson i've enjoyed learning it
myself
that we when we're in trauma like that
we have to force ourselves into higher
thinking
we have to say facts
are my friends what are the
facts
what's really happening what do you see
with your eyes
do you see people falling down dead all
around you
what are you really seeing with your
eyes
what is the actual facts
not what someone says is science not
what someone says
is
their political stance on something what
are the actual
facts
now when those occur
then you will act on those
but until then you need to get about
your business of having a life
you need to move on
and you need to put
stupid people
and stupid processes
and stupid conclusions
that were emotion based in your rear
view mirror
nothing wrong with emotions until they
start running your life and we've got a
whole generation or two that was raised
thinking their feelings are valid
your feelings aren't valid they're
feelings
it's valid to have feelings but it is
not valid to make decisions based on
your feelings that's what children do
children do what feels good
adults
use higher thinking skills devise a plan
and follow it
and we follow it based on the facts that
we see in front of us
what is the real world
what actually has happened
not what someone says might happen
not what someone thinks is going to
happen
not what you worry about at two o'clock
in the morning as your brain dreams up
all of these bizarre freaking scenarios
about your life
and don't we all do that we do
facts are your friends
when you're facing this stuff
we started telling you that with the
covet shutdown and the quarantine
almost two years ago
we started telling you that
you know i had just gotten back from a
trip to australia when covet hit and we
went into quarantine
sharon and i spent a month in australia
our first trip over there we loved
australia was fabulous and if you recall
the beginning of 2020 there were massive
fires in australia
if you were to watch the news in america
you would have thought the entire
continent of australia was on fire
we were there a month
and had you know had did you know went
to one area where the fires had been
and the uh the vegetation was already
starting to grow back
in those areas beautiful green valley
but the fires were real and they were
devastating and i'm not saying they're
they weren't horrible they were but they
they did not cover the entire continent
of australia
and we actually had
several people of course this is
pre-covered right the early early early
days of cove there were a few people in
the
airports with masks in those days but
very few
and we had lots of people in australia
tell us say hey would you please tell
americans that the entire continent did
not burn down because apparently
americans based on what they saw on fox
and cnn decided that australia was a
black charred mess not to go
and tourism was way down
because of the perception
of the fires
not the reality
the reality was a very small percentage
of the continent was actually affected
now the percentage that was affected was
a big problem and it was devastating i'm
not not saying that wasn't so but the
difference is what are the facts
versus what you saw on the news
because what you read in the newspaper
if anybody does still do that
what you read on some website
and what is the truth is very seldom the
same thing
what you see at a news report is so
jacked up
we got two three inches of snow today in
nashville and you would think according
to the news that it is 17 feet deep out
here
the facts are
that people in the south can't drive in
the snow so you probably should stay
home
but it's not knee deep
barely over the soles of your shoes
and if you have a four-wheel drive and
go slow you're gonna be just fine
and consequently i've been at work all
day so i'm not and i'm not shaming you
if you're not at work today in nashville
that's okay it's fine i understand i got
a bunch of our folks on our team didn't
come in and i'm not mad at them or
anything like that they if they can't
drive in the snow they shouldn't do it
but if you were to watch the news is my
point
according to the these newscasts these
weather forecasters sound like a beagle
chasing a rabbit
you would think
i have read articles written about dave
ramsey
that i don't even understand
how did you where did you get that
it has nothing to do with anything that
is me
nothing to do
that didn't happen
it just didn't occur
somebody just made it up
and you know it's amazing to me okay so
the point is folks don't make your
financial plan like our last caller in
that last segment
based on your fears
fears aren't facts
analyze the fearful situation and figure
out how much of it is actually factual
use your adult higher thinking skills
is the is the snow really 17 feet deep
is it really
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the show of course where we
talk about your life your work your
relationships and
your money thank you for being with us
joe is with us joe is in boston mass hi
joe welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave i i just got married a couple
months ago congratulations
thank you very much um and
my wife and i
after taxes we make about
56 a year and um
just did the math and uh you know get
trying to get on a budget and get out of
debt and our our expenses every month
come out to about
50
and not every month sorry every year we
have about uh fifty thousand dollars a
year so we only have a six thousand
dollar
savings and i know we're trying to get
out of debt too and um
really attack everything so i'm trying
to figure out how much extra uh we need
to make you know in a second or third
job uh you know for for the both of us
um as we move forward you know trying to
figure out how much
we need to
you know pay off debt and build up the
emergency fund how much debt do you have
uh it's about thirty thousand what's it
on
uh a car payment and student loans
how much do you owe on the car
about 24. okay
sell it
we just we just bought it uh shouldn't
we say
you make 56 000 a year you put 25 with 5
000 into a car that's going down in
value that you can't afford to pay the
payments on
we make
80s but you know take take-home pay is
56
and contain about 400 a month in the car
yeah you shouldn't bought that car that
was a mistake
yeah it's the reason your budget's tight
one time for you did that
yeah it's 5 000 a year
yeah
and it's going down in value
yeah
this wasn't the conversation you wanted
to have is it
i i i had a feeling it would go this way
and it was i knew it was stupid when i
bought it
i'm sorry
pick it on the newlyweds so pick it on
the newlyweds well you can do what you
want man uh but the the the
you know you can pick up an extra job
and and here's the thing as long as you
have vehicles
that equal half your annual income or
greater you're going to struggle with
finance
and you guys do because you put her car
with your car you're over half your
annual income
and uh or really really close and
this was an impulsive
i owe myself kind of purchase
and um it was it was a mistake so
you can fight your way through it if you
want to fight your way through it i
don't think it's worth it to fight your
way through i think it's a stupid car
get rid of it but um but that really
shocked your system when i said it out
loud so
if you want to fight through it fight
through it but here's the thing get on a
written
budget and then work like six extra jobs
and you know how much do i mean to make
it uh my extra job twenty four thousand
dollars if you're gonna keep a stupid
car
uh because it's got your it's got your
finances constipated that's what it
amounts to you're all blocked up and
that's why you're calling me you can't
breathe
and so
that that's what you're looking at now
you know
uh
i i
you know
again if you want to fight through it
you can it's the slow and the hard way
to do it
um and if i went through i think you so
try it for a few months and you may look
up in the fall and go wow this is really
a bad thing i'm not liking this i think
dave was right he kind of scared the
crap out of me and i'm not sure i like
talking to him i don't even like him
that much but
maybe he was right
so
because our goal here is to make sure
that we give you the information joe
that's going to do the best for you
because we love you and we want you to
win
thank you for calling jeff is with us in
austin texas hi jeff how are you
hey dave i'm great thanks for asking how
are you better than i deserve what's up
man i've got a question about uh
retirement investing
and my wife and i recently
surpassed baby step six way to go
and i was you okay and thank you for
guiding us through it too
um
so our we have
i have a 401k she has a 403 b
with 15 of those i also have a
separate ira
that uh my ira and my 401k are about
equal in money
and now that we're
debt-free
um
we're looking at what we're going to
invest in my company also offers a
a uh
457b
that i've never contributed to but now
that
you know end of the year we're doing
investment or uh benefit
elections and all that and i see this
thing every year and i don't know
anything about it yeah it's just my
question all 457 is deferring
compensation it's deferred comp
and it's okay if you don't anything else
in your case what's your household
income
about 180. way to go man congratulations
not a payment in the world no house
payment no nothing right
that's correct they're just amazing
congratulations can you see me smiling
yeah i can i can hear it way to go you
should be you you should be proud all
right so what i want to do is i want to
max out our 403b max out your 401k and
max out two roth iras and then let's
just move on with life
that's going to make you so stinking
rich you're not going to be able to
breathe
it's going to be amazing i'll just max
out what we have max out max out not 15
baby step 7 is no longer 15 baby step 7
is take the government's hands off of
any money you can
by utilizing roth ira's 401 case and 403
b's you could do the 457 it would be
okay but you're going to be just fine
doing that i probably would start some
other investing if i want to do
something in addition to maxing out all
of those
but
you max out all those put the most you
can in the 401k the most you can in her
403b and the most you can in two roth
iras and all in good growth stock mutual
funds all growing you have so much money
it's going to be unbelievable very very
well done
absolutely amazing that's just so cool
another another baby steps millionaire
right there folks that's that's who
we're talking to i'm so excited about
this new book coming out next week it's
just fun
just absolute fun
so you can still get it because it
doesn't come out until tuesday
if you jump online right now at
ramseysolutions.com for 20 and we'll
throw in 150 worth of goodies
so go ahead and get the baby steps
millionaire's book it's the only book
i've done in the last eight years and it
may be the last one i do who knows
i'm planning on another one i wasn't
planning on doing this one
but i just felt like i needed to
convince you guys again that you can do
this stuff because the end game is to
become wealthy and outrageously generous
that's in game here
with the money thing anyway
and so i'm going to show you how i'm
going to make the case
even to those of you who don't think
that dave knows anything about wealth
building i'm going to make an arithmetic
case for an arithmetic
a mathematical case let's just do it
that way for you that you can't deny
ramsey solutions.com get it
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america we're
glad you're here open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the ramsey show parker is with
us in houston texas hey parker welcome
to the ramsey shack
thank you mr ramsay how are you today
better than i deserve what's up in your
world
so just to give you a bit of context i'm
22 years old i'm married i'm completely
debt free i have a year left in my
master's and my wife is an accountant
right now about a year ago i
inherited about half a million dollars
from my grandfather in seven individual
stocks and he was a broker advisor in
his career
and candidly is
pretty obsessed with these stocks and
has a pretty tight hand i just want to
honor god with this wealth and wanted to
call you to see
how financially i can handle this you
know tax-free growth does it unwind the
positions and putting them in mutual
funds and also relationally how i could
talk to my grandfather about you know
pulling the money possibly out of these
positions that he's invested for me
wow what's your master's in
uh finance and commercial real estate
okay good for you
thank you okay
so
you you didn't inherit them because he
didn't pass
that's true he did uh that's right he's
still alive so he gave or gifted them to
me about a year ago when i turned 21.
wow what a wonderful gift
it is yes sir 500 000 worth of stocks
and seven stocks and he's
made all his money in this made the
money in these stocks and so he's very
emotionally invested in
this process
yes sir he is and i want to honor him
i went on to the lord and i want to you
know manage this well yes sir yeah
okay
so uh personality wise is is um how does
he react when you start talking to him
about this
i so i haven't brought up
if you did you know him
you start talking to him about this is
he going to be dismissive of you
or
is he pretty open-handed and once he
gave it to you as a gift he's released
it or does he still feel like
you by god ought to do it the way he
says
i think it's going to be more towards
the latter of likely advice on hey i
think you're making a mistake here
if that if that makes sense where you
know i've seen these
been with these stocks for x years and i
know there's you know this that the
other with them and um i don't think you
should do that and and probably more on
on that
side of things if i were to put it and
then if you went ahead and did it it's
gonna
he's gonna be really upset
i would think so yes sir yeah
wow
well uh
yeah there's a lot of stuff going on
here
because i kind of put myself the reason
i'm hesitating i kind of put myself
almost in grandpa's shoes for a minute
because i am that guy right i'm the guy
with a lot of opinions and i'm the
grandpa so i could be on the other side
of this and and i might be acting like
you're talking about it
so i'm trying to think throughout it how
to treat this this character oh my gosh
because i kind of like him oh my gosh um
even though i disagree with the
technicalities of this all right so
well i think there's a different
conversation that you just have
okay
and um
here's the thing there's a story in the
bible of nehemiah
building the walls rebuilding the walls
around jerusalem with
king nebuchadnezzar's permission
and when he went back to do that the
in order to
get the help of the people he didn't go
in and announce
we're all going to get our button gear
and rebuild these walls and do a lot of
hard work
and uh because you know he didn't make
like a pronouncement instead he just
walked around the city oh for days and
days for months
saying did you guys notice the walls are
down
you know when the walls are down we're
susceptible to attack from enemies you
know when the walls are down the pride
of jerusalem is taken away when the
walls are down this is and he just kept
talking about did y'all notice the walls
are down here's the bad things that
happen when the walls are down the walls
are down the walls are down i'm
concerned about the walls being down and
pretty soon people started coming up to
him the leaders of the people and saying
did you know the walls are down and he
went no you're kidding
and you know what i'm saying and so he
he he didn't uh he
he wasn't manipulative but he uh
drew them into the conversation and i
think that's your only shot here
because otherwise you're going to be an
ungrateful little 21 year old snot and
you don't want to be that guy right no
sir
not at all you're not that guy you're
not that guy you're a wonderful young
man and so i would sit down with grandpa
and go
you know what
here's what i see
i see
i just got five hundred thousand dollars
did you know that this guy gave me five
hundred thousand dollars grandfather
it's amazing
did you this guy he just gave me five
hundred 500 000 i mean did you see him
do that that was pretty amazing and just
let him kind of soak in a little bit and
go you know and
you know i'm i'm new at all this stuff
but grandpa this this uh the stock thing
is not very well diversified from what
i've been learning and it scares me
and just let him talk about it
he may get more entrenched in his
position when he does that
but but he also might
uh you know come along and you know you
just keep keep presenting him with the
problem
i'd like to talk to you about this but i
don't know how to talk to you about this
because i don't want to be ungrateful
and i certainly don't want to harm my
relationship and i also want to honor
god
and this scares me
and i'd like to i don't know how to talk
to you about this because i i you got
you're so strong in your opinions and i
i and
i i i
would you teach me how to talk to
somebody like you
you know you know what i'm saying this
kind of a
and just wearing him down over several
months
every time you're with him you have
these conversations where you're just
pulling him into the
discussion about how grateful you are
and how you want to honor god and how
scared you are and how this is an
intimidating thing because you you're
caught between your opinion and
and his um and your desire to please him
because that's exactly where you're
caught you know and just say it all out
loud and let grandpa help me solve his
problem
and he may come to the point he throws
up his hand he goes hey listen just do
whatever you want this is what i think
but i'll be okay with whatever you want
because i love you and if you can get
him there then you got him right that's
you can do whatever you want to do
because that's really what he should
have done
one of my things is i i have a rule i
don't give people money that won't
accept my input but once i've given them
the money i no longer control them
that's the line and that's the line he's
crossed here a little bit i don't like
that but i understand how he did it
because i would do that if i hadn't
pushed myself to do that because i'm a
pretty controlling person anyway it's my
nature
and so i uh that's why i can kind of
kind of back
reverse engineer this a little bit out
loud in front of everybody you and me
right because it's a great conversation
it's a great boundaries dr john delony
conversation i wish john was with me
today to
chime in on this but um
that's probably how i would get at it
and and
and just
i don't want to
dishonor you but i also don't want to
feel like you gave me something that i
can't do what i want to do with that's
kind of weird
and i don't want to dishonor god and i
don't want to i mean what if these
stocks went sideways grandpa how bad
would you and me and god feel you know i
mean
i didn't think god would care much but
you know you these are the kind of
things that just run through my head and
just have these instead of coming in and
making pronouncements
like i talked to dave ramsey and i'm
putting it in mutual funds it's my money
you gave it to me you no longer have a
say which is technically accurate
but it's not going to go well
right
right and so i wouldn't do that
um and you're gonna be okay in seven
stocks you're not gonna lose all your
money you know it is a higher risk
portfolio
right
and he has to say that if you said it to
him
it's a higher risk portfolio
and i'm 21 and the risk scares me
i wanna i wanna but i wanna honor you
and i wanna and yet i wanna be a man and
have my own opinion and how do i do all
that grandpa well i i think you draw him
in like that
he's going to start talking against
himself before he knows it
um it's probably what would happen to me
hey man thanks for the call you're a
neat young guy what a wonderful
opportunity is in front of you
very cool this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage vincent is here hey
vincent how are you i'm great how are
you
better than i deserve sir welcome where
do you live i live in chicago cool
welcome to nashville and showing up here
on a snowy day
yeah i didn't know you guys get this
much uh snow down here we didn't either
and you can attest to the fact that
nobody here knows how to drive in it so
it's very very interesting the uh
snowmageddon is two and a half inches so
uh but there you go so welcome dude good
to have you thank you it's a pleasure to
finally meet you i feel like i already
know you good to see you you do we've
been hanging out together for a while
so how much debt have you paid off
vincent i've paid off 90 743 and 82
cents way to go how long did that take
27 months wow
and your range of income during that
time 25 000 up to 100 000. whoa there's
a story there
okay so what kind of debt was the 91 000
so i had
79 000 student loans and 11 on my car
okay very very good how old are you
i'm i just turned 26 last week so good
for you good for you so what do you do
for a living i'm an accountant okay so
what happened from the 25 to 127 months
so
i started my debt-free journey right
before i graduated um april of 2019 so
okay um it was about four months before
i started my full-time job um i finished
up my coursework finished up my cpa and
i started looking towards
the next steps in life and and
addressing all the student loans that i
had accrued over the years sure um and
pride in time for covent
yeah exactly um
so i was i was talking with one of my
friends and
he told me about the podcast and that's
how i kind of got in touch with um your
program started listening to the podcast
um
and then yeah that's that's kind of how
i started my uh my debt free journey wow
very cool so how did you go from 25 000
because you were just getting you were
just doing other odd jobs and then
exactly but you got the big accounting
job now
exactly so when i was starting um i just
got a i just got a um
a job at like a local pizza place making
pizzas um
i heard on one of the one of the early
episodes that i listened to you're not
going to see the inside of a restaurant
unless you worked there so
i figured
i'd learn how to make make some pizzas
very cool well you did that in 27 months
that's pretty impressive yep you haven't
done much else yeah yeah and then the
other thing that helped was um i picked
up uber ubereats
for for about the last year or so um and
then i just just went crazy with that so
there's such a high demand
for drivers in
chicago that i was able to to kind of um
increase my income that way as well yeah
i bet i bet you did really well
and now you're done
all done how's it feel it feels
incredible like like i'm free so i mean
you're a guy of singular purpose when
you sit on this i can just tell about
talking to you looking at you you just
went for it yes sir there's no real no
real question you just go in all in all
in yep yeah we're going to jump in the
deep end yeah good for you
so what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
the key to getting out of debt is um
everyone says it's it's the budget if
you don't get the budget right nothing
else will work so
um why do you think that is i mean
you're an accountant
well there's a power to that and that's
why everybody says that it's true
it's not just cliche but i mean as an
accounting person you and our numbers
guys we're geeks right so we we see
these numbers all the time we see things
in numbers other people don't see maybe
there's something powerful about this
budget thing exactly like if you don't
assign ever if you don't have an
assignment for every dollar before the
month begins then the ants are going to
take it
carry all the dollars off so it's like
that's good i like that the ants are
gonna cause i can see it though like i'm
carrying a potato chip away yeah it's
like
exactly it's like five dollars here
twenty dollars here um if you don't have
that that plan of what you're going to
do with every single dollar then
um
then then your financial plan is really
not going to work so yeah you're just
stuck yeah sticking to a plan is is
probably the well it gives you the it
gives you the guard rails to stay in and
that way you don't slip off the road
accidentally exactly yeah yeah well done
man well done very well done this is
great how's it feel you're done
feels it feels amazing um
i'm uh i'm honestly
like kind of in disbelief like it's it's
it still feels like surreal um just like
all like after all the sacrificing and
um just to finally be done and um
recently got engaged to my fiance
madison so yeah
sure see it madison let's see the ring
hold it up
she was my biggest cheerleader along the
way and
um we had definitely a lot of um date
nights in where we just make food at one
of our apartments and
you know watch a movie and she's she's
always been loving and supportive so
yeah when's the date uh it's gonna be
october all right good very fun and good
for you man thank you this is so good
and what does she do for a living she is
also an accountant okay of course
of course so you guys are gonna do
extremely well yeah that's amazing yeah
very very good well that's the number
two
uh
uh career of that we found in the
millionaire research are people who
become millionaires accountants number
one's engineer number three's teacher so
um very cool man yeah i love it you're
awesome man you're heroes what a great
way to start your life completely free
got something to talk about she's
cheering you on this is everything's on
the right track you're just you're
amazing well done you're a hero man good
job good job so what are your parents
did you grow up in a family that was
responsible like this and or are they
looking at you thinking you're crazy
no absolutely not um they're looking at
me like i'm crazy they actually had your
book they never read it um but i was i
was fortunate enough to
um to receive it from them
um but
i was always taught to build up my
credit score
and um invest so
so
paying off paying off all my debt kind
of ran counter to
what i had been taught like my entire
life um so i mean they're definitely
supportive of me and oh they love you
they want you to win but they think
you're a little weird yeah yeah exactly
yeah um that's right that's kind of how
i knew it was working it was like my
friends thought i was weird
everybody
you know kind of thought i was doing
something different so um
that let me know that was right on track
that does give you energy it really does
if your broke friends are making fun of
your financial plan it means you got a
good one yeah that's good very good very
cool good job man well done well done
well done what a great life you've
mapped out for yourself thank you well
we got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you it comes out next week but we'll
give you an advanced copy today
uh because that's definitely you in
madison's next chapter uh is to get on
the business of uh building some wealth
and being outrageously generous as you
go along so and you're definitely
definitely in a position to do that
thank you
very very cool very well done
also a copy of the total money makeover
for you to give away to somebody and
disrupt their lives and disrupted yours
and uh get you started and
that's exactly right if anybody asks
what you did you just hand them that and
say this is what i did right here that's
what i did right there so uh very cool i
want to hear from you when your baby
steps millionaire too yes sir you'll be
on your way absolutely very good stuff
all right it's vincent from chicago
illinois 91 000
paid off in 27 months making 25 to 100.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three
two
one i'm debt free
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's how it's done right there man
that's exactly what we do around here
that's pretty cool so it doesn't matter
if you're 26 or 36 or you're 46 that's
what you do
56 or 66 it doesn't matter just put it
whatever decade you want to put in there
this is doable
it's very doable he did this in 27
months
he was making no money
got his first job with his masters in
accounting got a cpa and added to that
substantial income by delivering uber
eats and pizzas
then he's done
did he did he deliver pizzas the rest of
his life did he work who buried the rest
of his life no he did it for 27 months
not even really probably 24 months
but the whole journey was 27 months long
so this what this what this guy is
telling you what vincent's life is
telling you it's speaking to you right
now when you're listening to this when
you're looking at this on youtube it's
speaking to you very clearly
you know what it's telling you
vince's life is telling you you can do
this
you can do this
and it's worth doing
it's worth the trouble
and you need to get about the business
of being a grown-up
it's past time for you to get about the
business of being a grown-up
yeah i'm talking to you
this
is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for joining us america we're glad
you're here this is the ramsey show
common sense for your dollars and cents
for that matter for your life common
sense is so rare in america today when
you've got it it's like having a
superpower
john is in atlanta hi john welcome to
the ramsay show
hey there dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
not much
my wife and i are in baby step two
we have about
153
000 in debt
um
we are toying with the idea of
potentially selling our home in order to
become debt free
wow 153 count the house
no it does not what's that on there's
about
there's about 235 on the house okay how
much what's the 253 on
the the 153 yes i'm sorry most mostly
student loans
how much are student loans
no
i don't have it exactly how much is a
car right in front of me
of
27. how much is the boat
no vote
okay
um what else is in there besides a car
and a student loan
that's about it we paid off our all of
our credit cards are gone got you what's
your household income we paid off about
two we paid off about 25 000 last year
good for you what's your household
income
uh around 130. okay good
okay
what's the house worth
i haven't had an appraisal on it um but
trending in that area uh that house
would probably go for around 400
okay
okay
all right uh
do you like the house
we like the house but it's
not a
i think we're both at the point now
where
renting an apartment for a year or two
doesn't sound like such a bad idea
um 100 debt-free
9-11 yeah yeah 100 debt free sounds
awfully fun
yeah it does
okay
and you've been working on this for a
year
yes sir okay
all right this question often comes up
when people first start
and if it's when you first start i'll i
will tell you to try it for a year and
see how it goes
and see what you can come up with
because selling a house is very
expensive emotionally
financially
tears up your time
it takes a chunk out of your year you
know there's just a it's a it's not as
simple as uh you know taking a taking a
pair of jeans back to the store that
didn't fit i mean it's a problem you
know what i'm saying right
yeah it's taxing on you and that's why i
it's the last thing i tell people to do
is to sell their house and if you told
me you didn't like it that would help
you know but all you're saying is it's
an okay house but we're at the point
that we we can see that this is going to
take us
you know this is going to take us three
hard years
almost maybe even a little bit more or
we can give up this house and be done
with this
right and this is the trade-off
yeah
there's not a wrong answer
john it's it would be a matter of uh
personal preference
uh what would sharon and i do
if we were ambivalent about the house
meaning we were kind of in the middle we
don't care one way or the other we'd
probably sell it
because we would we would relish the now
that we know what it feels like to be
debt-free we would relish that idea more
than we would home ownership for the
next because in one year you can save up
a down payment start the process again
right
right yeah so go live in an apartment
for one year with everything paid for
tight budget
build you up a nice emergency fund a
nice down payment and then go buy you a
house on a 15-year fix where the
payment's no more than a fourth of your
take-home pay
and so you're one year out of the
housing market
you're taking advantage of this white
hot market right now
one year or
18 months from today it will have calmed
down
from where it is now somewhat i don't
know how much but it will have calmed
down it's not gonna get worse
uh it's crazy out there right now so um
great time to sell that's another reason
to think about it so yeah we probably
would
but if you guys talk about it tonight
and you go you know we're just really
good we're going to gut it out we're
going to fight through this for three
years and knock this debt out and keep
this house that's not a that's not a
wrong answer
okay because there's nothing here that's
demanding that you do this
it's a matter of it you are making the
choice between
making a move
apartment for a year buying another
house
uh 18 months later uh give or take and
you're making that choice between that
and being debt-free today or fighting
for three years that that it's just the
trade-off of that and that both of those
are things that give you a good outcome
five years from now
five years from now with either way you
go you're going to be in great shape
got it so just make the choice which way
you want to play this but i probably
wouldn't it wouldn't i
i don't own any houses i'm that tied to
i like real estate but there's stinking
house on every corner so i just don't
get all jacked up about houses
um
so i probably i i i'm out of there
because houses to me are just commodity
i don't i don't get a lot of emotion
about them
but um but but
sharon might argue with me on that so
and then i might let her win because she
does
often janna is with us janice and
pullman whoa i hit the wrong button now
jenna's in pullman washington hi jana
how are you
i'm doing all right snow has my kids all
home today so cool me too
yeah me too all my kids are home today
what's up
uh so when i was in high school i sold
animals at the fair through 4-h and my
fifth grade teacher told me that i
should invest some of it
i did not understand what
wise wonderful that advice was until i
was an adult until the fbu
now my 12 year old son sold an animal's
affair this year got a big check and we
were talking about what to do with it
and he says investing sounds like fun or
sounds interesting
how much did he get
uh he got like a thousand dollars okay
and we already have some set in savings
um so i'm just wondering how can we
teach him i'd like to let him invest
even just a little bit so he can learn
about it and he's my oldest he's very
responsible he's my big favor
um you know he got a thousand from this
check but he has like eight hundred
dollars saved up from past years just
because he doesn't spend
um and other than that was like his
spending money he saved him he's not
really spending it so
okay i'd like to teach him about but i
don't want to make him into like a
little day trader no no no no no no
we're not doing that so how can i say
well the downside the downside is is
that it's pretty boring
to do it right the proper way to teach
him is to put the money in mutual funds
and let him just watch the mutual fund
it's pretty boring
uh it's not because it's not day trading
it's not single stocks and we're not
studying companies and we're not
i don't want to teach him that i don't
want him doing that i don't think that's
the right way to do it so i'm not going
to model that
um and so if you want to do it i would
just sit down with a smartvestor pro and
pick a mutual fund and put it in there
and then once a month sit down and go
over the mutual fund statement with him
not once a day
once a month and say okay here's the
number of shares you have
and here's the share price multiply
those two and you know what your account
is now worth
and this is how this works and here's
how here's the you can review the stocks
that are inside the mutual fund
and look at those companies if you want
to
uh and you know learn about how a mutual
fund works and learn about the actual
paperwork of opening up the mutual fund
and
and but it's really not there's a lot a
lot of activity once you get it open
it's just kind of tracking it
um do i keep him away from people like
my like his grandfather who
does a lot of single stops
yes okay
because i'm not trying to teach him to
do that
listen
why teach him to do something you don't
think it's a good idea
you know i i didn't i teach my kids how
to do single stocks i taught them to do
mutual funds now in my case what i did
the way i taught them was that they just
tracked their college fund that i was
funding
they didn't put their money in mutual
funds until they were adults
but they knew how mutual funds work
because we sat and had the little nerd
conversation at the table with my money
that i was doing
and so if they rolled their eyes and
were bored it wasn't the end of the
world
but it's not a real active
process
real investing is not
that you know in speculating gambling is
an active process
and i wouldn't teach him that
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country to find a
station near you head to thermsyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america we're glad you're
here it's common sense for your work
your life your money and your
relationships it's what we talk about
here every day
nettie is with us in mesa arizona to
start off this hour hi neddy how are you
i pushed the wrong button
uh i'm lit i'm losing it there you are
neddy how are you eddie
hi i'm doing good uh i just have a quick
question
um
i
i uh i'm on babysit number five
and we've got my wife and i read your
book we have two kids
um
we're just kind of stuck in the college
fund
you know we believe and i know there's
studies showing like you know sometimes
kids that just get handed you know
their
you know money or to pay for stuff um
times it ends up hurting them more
because they get a freebie um
reading your book i don't really feel
like i got a clear
direction of why
two to have a college fund
you know why we would uh
why we would look for a call
unfortunately
so you're saying you would prefer that
that that not to furnish any money for
your kids college and for them to pay
for their own because you're afraid
you're that when kids are handed money
you're going to ruin them
eventually like to have them something
so don't let an inheritance but i don't
want to give it to them right when they
get out of high school or you know or
something they want them to work for it
how old are your kids
and then one's uh six months
i'm sorry your phone broke up six months
and what
years
two years okay
all right still little well there's
nothing wrong with what you're saying if
you want to go that route i've got a
friend who is a professional football
player and uh
his school is paid for because he went
to college on a football scholarship and
he's a you know he grew up in a real
hardcore blue collar household and he
had to work for everything and he said
his kids are going to have to work or
they're going to get a scholarship
they're going to figure it out he'll
help him show him how to do it but he's
not giving him a dime
and
he's real hardcore on that and if you
want to be that that's okay there's
nothing wrong with that um the vast
majority of people that we work with
want to help fund their kids college one
way or the other
the uh and that's why the baby step is
there we did fund our kids college and
uh
we did not ruin our children in the
process
uh yeah so
the uh you know the the the sub that i
think that that
you know the thing i would think on from
a parenting standpoint i'm not arguing
with you you're welcome to do what
you're talking about there's nothing
wrong with what you're talking about
okay but the reason that i went a
different direction was i discovered
that my children turning out to have a
work ethic
and have integrity and have character
uh didn't have as much to do with how
much money i gave them as how i made
them behave
yeah it's true and so my kids know how
to knew how to work before they went to
college work ethic was required in our
household i'm a hard-working guy and i
believe in hard work the harder i work
the luckier i get you know and that kind
of stuff i i'm that guy you know so uh
our kids had jobs they had jobs at the
house they had chores they had to do
they got paid for the chores some of
them some of them they did just because
you love your mother shut up and you
help your mother right and so we we did
some of that and we mixed it up and and
so and and they're getting help for
college was contingent upon them
behaving
if they weren't going to behave
uh
correctly then you know you're not gonna
be out here playing beer pong and uh you
know sleeping around all over the place
and you know this is not a chance for
you to try to show out all the stupid
human tricks in one four-year period of
time me fund it
you know so we're not doing that either
so the the the gift for college was
contingent upon
that but by the time they got to college
it was not really a probability they
were going to do that because we'd
already handled those behavior issues
long before college
those people that show out usually
weren't taught to behave long before
college
or they were clamped down on so hard
that was the first time they ever were
allowed to have their own thoughts
uh and they blow up at college one of
the two
so uh
you know that's just kind of a parenting
discussion we can have
but but at the end of that discussion if
you still say
hey i'm not giving them a dime the
little turkeys are gonna work for it i'm
not gonna be mad about that
uh i will challenge you that it's a big
bill and you need to show them a method
to get to be able to pay for it
teach them entrepreneurial skills so
they can start their own run their own
business while they're in school make
good money not be flopping whoppers and
hope they can get through school
teach them about selecting an
inexpensive school
because they're not going to have much
money to go to school with
teach them about getting scholarships
teach them about getting good grades to
get good scholarships and being good
citizens to get good scholarships and
teach them some of the methodology like
we have in the ramsey book debt-free
degree
you should coach them if you're not
especially if you're not going to give
them money
but there's no moral requirement that
says you have to pay for your children's
college or you're a bad parent
uh and on the other hand if you do pay
for your kids college it doesn't say
you're necessarily a bad parent either
that somehow you allowed them to be
trust fund babies with no sense of
dignity identity or personal
responsibility those things should be
taught independent of money
the money then should the way they
handle money should be the result of the
character you grow in them as a dad and
as a mom really good discussion man
thank you for calling in with that uh
marisol is with us in augusta georgia is
it marisol did i say that right
marisol yes okay
yes can you hear me
yes how can i help
hey um i just have uh maybe one or two
questions so um
those of the story
i can say this year 2022 about um
20 grand good it's like because right
now i don't have um nothing in my
savings i had five thousand dollars but
i used it to pay my mom's surgery a
couple weeks back
right now i'm basically the breadwinner
in my household i mean my stepfather has
a job
but i make more than he does so he
covers
most of the um bills in the house and i
cover basically the medical bills for my
mom and my uh dad
it's really stressful because um how old
are you
i'm 25 about to be 25 what do you make
i make about 48. what do you do here
i'm a diesel mechanic
okay why don't you get out on your own
let everybody else run their own life
like go on my like on my own let them
leave go get you an apartment and run
your own life and quit taking care of
everybody else and everybody else taking
care of you
well um i used to live by myself and i
got involved in some pretty bad stuff
and financially everything went down
so i went back to my mom's house and she
doesn't ask for anything i just go ahead
and
pay for her medical bills are you healed
are you healed from dealing with bad
stuff
i'm yeah i'm healed it was i was
involved in pretty like bad stuff like
well so don't do bad stuff and go get on
your own that's what i would do
hang on i'm gonna send you a copy of the
total money makeover to show you what
you do what you do with the money while
you're doing that
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you for joining us america this is
the ramsey show one week from today
thursday january the 13th we will be in
the middle of book launch week for the
new book baby steps millionaire and
we're going to do our free live stream
event called building wealth in 2022.
in-person tickets are sold out over 1500
people registered in the first few days
that we put the
in person alive event up for sale
uh the good news is you can watch this
as a live stream and we're not gonna
charge you a dime over 60 000 people are
already registered to watch the live
stream rachel cruz george campbell and i
are going to talk about how to build
wealth this year not only about what's
going on in the real world and
we'll discuss stuff like crypto and nfts
and we'll discuss the things that are
going on in the investment world there's
a real get rich quick thing
vibe but moving around in america today
and we're going to discuss it in a way
that's understandable without having to
call anybody names and then as a result
of doing it we will get called names
[Laughter]
welcome to social media but hey we're
looking forward to this exactly one week
from today building wealth in 2022 is a
free
live stream one night only event
thursday january 13th join the thousands
who've already registered for free
by going to
ramseysolutions.com
wealth and you can register ramsey
solutions dot com slash wealth and we
are in the last few days of your ability
to buy the baby steps millionaire's book
for 20. it actually launches next week
and the 20 deal will be gone plus you
get
all the goodies if you do it in the
pre-order so do the pre-order on it
because you get the the e-book and the
audio book included
you get the uh legacy journey e-book and
audio book included
um you get
uh all kinds of other stuff i mean
there's a whole pile of things just
check it out at ramseysolutions.com
it's over 150 worth of items if you
pre-order so go ahead and pre-order the
book this week
get it this weekend let people know that
they need to get it over the weekend 20
is a deal
books have gone up because paper has
gone up
and our costs on the books have gone up
and other publishers when we look at
what they're doing their costs have gone
up and that's the thing
that's the deal
so be sure and do all of this
ramseysolutions.com marco is in los
angeles hi marco welcome to the ramsay
show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
all right so um just a quick um history
about me i'm a 33 year old male i'm
currently making about 125 on an annual
salary
i have no debt except for a car payment
and i'm currently i currently owe
26 000 on it
however my goal is to own a
my goal is to become a homeowner so my
question is
should i sell that vehicle and buy
something in cash or should i pay or
should i finish paying off my car before
i begin saving for a house
how much do you owe on the car
six thousand you told me that i'm sorry
how much do you have in savings
uh
about forty forty thousand okay
all right
um
what's the car what kind of car
a good jeep cheap cloud eater
you like it
uh it's okay
okay
um
what would i do if i woke up in your
shoes i'm 33 years old to make 125 000.
got 40 000 in the bank i want to buy a
house i have a 26 thousand dollar car
debt
i'd write a check as soon as you get off
the phone
jump online and pay the car off
that leaves you 14 000
and no car payment i'd get on a tight
budget you got nobody to control but you
that's easy
just decide to control you
and make it 125 000 i'd save a huge pile
of money by this time next year for my
down payment i'd buy a house next spring
with a massive down payment
i bet you could save
60 or 80 000 bucks if you really leaned
into it
that's what i would do
if i woke up in your shoes
aaliyah is in trenton new jersey hi alia
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you hello mr ramsay hi what's up
um so
a quick overview i recently started
following my dream of studying a
master's in architecture in 2020 good um
i'm about a quarter thank you i'm about
a quarter finished with it um it's about
26
000
for a year i do work full time
but more recently i kind of started this
kick with financial freedom and just
kind of changing the trajectory of my
family lineage
um not to mention this year i'm in the
process of donating my kidney to my mom
um whoa so my question
so
um i guess if you were in my shoes what
will you do um i
kind of have three options paul's school
and pay off my debt then return once i'm
done i can also stretch out my program
and pay as i go or should i get like a
certification in a related field such as
ux um to fund college once
i'm debt free
what are you doing another option what
do you do now
oh
i'm currently a service rep
i'm sorry a service rep
yeah so essentially a junior uh sales
rep
okay
now you're you're studying architecture
but you're trying to get your masters in
architecture and it's a four-year
program
it's a three-year program
but because i work full-time i have to
uh
study it that is lower rate than the
typical person
[Music]
and what do you make a year
60 000
good for you okay
i wonder what it at what point in this
process that you could join an
architectural firm in a junior position
that wasn't licensed
yeah i've been looking into that um it's
just a little difficult to get into it
because it does require some experience
and my background is in business so it's
just a little challenging
no it is challenging no question
everything in front of you is
challenging though oh yeah you don't
have it you didn't have anything on your
list that wasn't challenging
oh my gosh i mean welcome to life huh
but the uh uh
how old are you
26. good for you good for you thank you
the good news is that you are thinking
about doing all of the things you're
considering doing on purpose instead of
letting life happen to you
so i predict that you're going to be
successful because if you keep doing
that
that does lead you to success sometimes
you have to go around the barn twice to
get there but it'll lead you there
because you keep being you keep thinking
about the future you keep thinking about
where i want to end up and what are the
steps to get there so that i end up
there you have a clear what we call
desired future right
and the desired future is is that at the
end of this
the first at the end of this chapter of
the story you are working as a master's
degreed
licensed architect
that's our goal agreed
yes sir so then we have to ask ourselves
what is the shortest most efficient
process to get there
which is kind of what you're asking me
um
it occurs to me even if you took a pay
cut
if you could get on even if you're doing
the business aspects of an architectural
firm for an architectural firm for
instance if you were helping them in
business development meaning you're
helping them get new clients kind of
like you do now but you did it for an
architectural firm that they might be
willing to pay for
your education
while you're working there i mean if you
made 50 000 a year and they paid for
your education we got a net increase
agree
yes sir i just made that up i don't know
where that job exists but i know it
exists somewhere i just don't know where
and what you got to go through to get
there now uh
there's the kidney process you also got
to kind of factor that thing in what's
the recovery time on that the down time
uh because you don't take a new job and
then be out for six weeks that doesn't
work right
right correct so you kind of got to
think that through
uh
but i i think if you're careful you
probably can figure out a way to get
this degree without any additional debt
working
and you may or may not start parts of
that before or after
the kidney donation
which is an unbelievably wonderfully
charitable thing to do it says a lot
about your character
the good things about your character
so yeah that's probably what i would do
let me send you a couple of ken
coleman's books to help you with this
the proximity principle it's kind of
what i've got in mind while i'm talking
about this but also send your paycheck
to purpose which is what the process is
get that clear path going that he lays
out for you
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the ramsey show america we're
glad you're here dobie and kaya are with
us in
baltimore hi guys how are you
we're good how are you better than i
deserve i see on my screen you're
debt-free congratulations how much did
you pay off
you um we paid off 140 000
all right how long did this take
um it took exactly 16 months 16 months
and your range of income during that 16
months
so
we started out at 100 000
together and then
landed on 201 thousand dollars and
736.
your income went up 100 000 in 16 months
not bad
yeah i'd say so too yeah so what caused
that income to go up like that
well um
so i started working seven jobs and my
wife
picked up another job
for a total of nine jobs between the two
of us oh my gosh um so for
yeah
so for the six months um every single
day of the six months
i was working and my wife was working
most of the days as well wow that's
crazy crazy crazy go go go go go go what
kind of debt was the 140 000
um so primarily student loans and about
2 000 of it was in musical instruments
okay
oh wow
very cool what do y'all do for a living
with your main jobs
um so i am a physician assistant
um
and dovie is a paramedic
and a
david site manager yeah i run a covet
testing center and i
i also decided to to take you up on your
uh your advice and
uh sell everything but but the kids so i
started a business just
selling things on ebay on facebook all
right what what is your most profitable
uh what's your best side gig dovie
my best side gig would probably be
um selling stuff on
on facebook and ebay and stuff like that
i've sold watches i sold cars people
wanting to get rid of them from houses
um you know like their grandparents
passed away i take a commission off of
that and
i'm just selling stuff like that wow
cool good for you man you've been
getting after it
so uh how long you guys have been
married
uh eight years i think now almost nine
years so what happened 16 months ago
that let you on fire because you guys
are burning bright
um so
16 months ago we we started uh
we've been dave ish for maybe five years
but uh 16 months ago we decided that we
were really sick and tired of being sick
and tired and
having too much a month at the end of
the month
so
so we decided that we would get
completely uh
completely dave
and just go uh
because all intents we listened to
um total money makeover we were driving
up to visit friends in new york we
we uh we listened to total money
makeover the whole way up and then the
whole way down finished it
and from there we just uh we were
gazelle intense beans and rice
no internet no tv is that what flipped
the switch just the audiobook we kind of
rubbed it in your face well that and
for a while the reason we were dave-ish
is because we couldn't imagine how i
would get through pa school without
loans um at that point and then my first
job was something that would qualify me
for loan forgiveness
and for a while i was kind of stuck on
the idea of that being a good idea and
then we actually like you say to you sat
down and did the math on an excel
spreadsheet and kind of figured out that
with me staying there to try to get loan
forgiveness we would end up losing on
a lot of money that we could potentially
make if i changed jobs to something that
paid more and that allowed um dovie to
work more yeah and the net result is you
make more money net of the forgiveness
even yeah that's good good very good way
to go you guys
way to go how does it feel to be free
it's awesome it's really really great i
mean it just feels like there's so much
extra and
you know you can just give it away
you guys have been busting it i mean you
got to be a little tired
very tired we're towards the end of 3b
right now so we're gonna slow down in a
little bit but we're still we're still
running all right way to go guys way to
go way to go who was your biggest
cheerleader outside the two of you
somebody outside looking at you going go
go go go
so initially not really it was it was
pretty rough at when we started because
everybody was kind of hating on us but
um but then we we got into an fpu class
and our fpu
guides were very very much our
cheerleaders and they're good friends of
ours
and they even advised us to start our
own fpu class we we ran in a few classes
they were like if you guys if you if you
start if you lead a fpu class
i guarantee you you'll get out of debt
yeah before you finish the fbu class and
they were right yeah gave me the give
both of us the uh the
the the energy to just
you know
get the rest of it paid off really
really quickly well there's something
about being in the middle of it every
time every week you're in the middle of
it with other people that just fires you
back up and keeps you going
exactly yeah and it was nice to have the
community like it was also local so even
though it was online the class we
attended initially was all kind of
people from the community who we became
friends with and so it was nice to kind
of be in the same boat with with other
people who weren't you know keeping up
with the joneses and we're also kind of
using the same old lunchbox or whatever
to help kind of like not feel bad about
it driving a 91
car there you go
that's a badge of courage right there
isn't it yeah i like it just as a
temporary thing you drive like no one
else later you can drive like no one
else this is what you've been doing you
work like no one else you bad been you
now you can work like no one else you
don't have any payments anywhere way to
go
guys this is excellent thank you so
proud of you guys so what are you
telling people now you're in the
financial peace class you guys have been
busting it
you pay off 140 000 in 16 months what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is
um
definitely getting on the same page with
your spouse i know that's one that's
said often but it really does require
that that team effort that community
just within the
marriage
and you know for anyone who's not in a
marriage having a partner or a friend
like
essentially having that community having
that support because it can be really
easy to falter there's so much media
there's so many advertisements like
everything trying to tell you
not to do what dave says to do so to
have those people around i think is a
really big deal
and also to recognize that you know if
the math doesn't make sense that yeah
you've got to work more and you've got
to spend less and you just got to get
used to that idea
wow powerful good for you well you're
right financial peace university sets
you up in that community where you've
got the accountability you've got the
encouragement and you got other people
modeling and doing it right there with
you it's not like you're by yourself
then uh that you you got to have some
people around you cheering you on
pushing you
pulling you whatever it takes and that's
just it's necessary so so proud of you
guys very well done
your heroes great job
we got a copy of the baby steps
millionaires book for you we're going to
send it to you it comes out next week
and we'll send it to you then and
so you'll get a copy and brand new copy
of that because that's the next chapter
in your story for sure you're going to
be baby steps millionaires and then i'll
also send you a copy of the total money
makeover which is uh you know the
audiobooks what got you guys fired up so
you can give that hardback book away to
someone maybe disrupt their world get
them off of ish and get them moving i'm
proud of you guys well done
amazing thank you
140 000 paid off in 16 months making 100
to 200. oh man dovey and kia in
baltimore maryland count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream
three two
one
[Applause]
[Music]
let the next chapter begin baby
that's how you do it
and that couple's been working
[Applause]
wow impressive
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 13 4
the soul of the sluggard craves
and gets nothing
while the soul of the diligent
is richly supplied
wow that seems to apply to our last
caller doesn't it
i was working seven jobs
most people get ahead during the time
that others waste
henry ford
i like that open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
elizabeth is with us elizabeth is in des
moines iowa hi elizabeth welcome to the
ramsay show
hi how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up in your world
good
um so i am on board with becoming a
millionaire that sounds fantastic
um but the issue with that
is losing it all um my father worked
very hard to become a millionaire and uh
he suddenly passed away a couple years
ago about five years ago
and um
right around the same time my mom was
diagnosed with early onset dementia
and
yeah it was rough how old is your mom
now
she is 66 so she was 62 when she got
diagnosed but
i mean the science had been there for
years i had i had mentioned it it's just
it's really hard to get so your dad your
dad was your dad was like 60 years old
when he passed
he was 62. wow yeah okay yeah yeah i'm
sorry um
thank you yeah um
so
there was a silver lining in that which
is um
all of his assets it's sad but
pretty much most of his assets have gone
towards care for my mom
um
and
to be honest it's it's not enough
million dollars is not enough to pay for
early onset dementia care
um
even in assisted living if if you're
frugal about it and you really don't
want to be frugal about it
it's a lot of money
and doing the quick math
if there's only a three percent increase
each year on the run which it's been
five
for my mom
if i were to go through the same thing
my husband would basically have to pay
either
four million dollars out of pocket if i
were to live for about 20 years which is
what we were projecting for my mom or
he'd have to live on two thousand
dollars a month and have absolutely no
asset he couldn't have a house or a car
um
and long-term care insurance only pays
for six years of care
so financially i don't know what to do
in order to
make sure my husband's taken care of
because there's always medicaid for
if that happens to me but what about him
yeah
i'm so sorry for what you've been
through
um
and
your reaction is a uh
of great concern about this is a normal
reaction
um
but the statistics don't back up your
fears
which is good news um i'm hoping yes
they really don't um the number the
number of early onsets that live 20
years is
there's not any
they don't you know there's very very
few early onsets live 20 years
um it's been it's been pretty it's been
five years and
she's pretty healthy
we have had early onsets in our family
and i
walk through it and just i mean do a
little bit of research not just with
your mom's situation but with overall
and let's not talk about your mom i'm
not trying to wish
you know a short longevity on her that's
not what i'm saying no i know i'm not
that in delicate but um
but but here's the thing the the point
is is that the set of assumptions you're
using
uh are statistically so unlikely
the probability is so unlikely that
you're using on you
that your husband ends up this way that
i i
um
i think i you know i'm not gonna do it
i'm not gonna worry about it i think you
guys go about the business of building
wealth and plan on getting your six-year
long-term care and you're correct about
that
um
and
at 60 years old is when i would buy it
um and uh even though she had symptoms
because we could not
we could not get her long-term care
insurance because i understand the
doctors are a nurse yeah i understand
but again that's so unusual
statistically yeah the number of people
that use long-term care insurance prior
to 60 is
so statistically insignificant that it's
just i wouldn't do it if you want to buy
it at 55 because of your fears
that's fine but you're gonna pay you
know
three thousand bucks a year for five
years for a
0.001 chance is what you're doing
and
it's okay to do that but but you just
need to
let's
not um
it it's it's you should hurt
and you should grieve with what you've
been through and i'm sorry you're
hurting and grieving i i don't want that
for you but i also don't want that to
make your decision
i want you to use
facts not all of the hurt and the
feelings to make your decisions with on
this and and i am being in delicate and
telling you you're doing that right now
so don't yeah um you know
and what you're doing is a human
reaction and it means you're a good
daughter and a good person and it
doesn't mean you're you're an illogical
person or something like that it's a
normal thing but i'm not in the trees
with you so i can see the forest so
here's the thing i i would buy long-term
care insurance if you want to buy it a
few years early 57 even go ahead i
really wouldn't do it at 55
and i really would just get about the
business of building wealth and i
wouldn't try to do this and then the the
other thing i would do is i would
continue to learn
the care systems that are available
um to someone
and how you might do this more
economically than
maybe you started out thinking it was
going to cost
there's a lot of different care out
there a lot of different types of care a
lot of different ways to get at this and
and
um
uh even in home care so let me give you
an example okay our net worth is um
large enough that if it was four million
dollars it really wouldn't be a big deal
uh but we would end up spending four
million dollars on it at our house
because we would because for less than
four million dollars i can i can hire a
full-time nurse
and set up a full medical award inside
my house
and take care of someone have someone
taken care of you know for instance if
that happened to my wife okay
uh or if it happened to me she could do
that
and so there's there's other ways to
for your husband to deal with this if
that comes up i'm not suggesting you
change your mom's care plan that you
have
and i'm not suggesting this is cheap
it's not cheap but uh but but
the numbers you're giving are
so unlikely
that the
hopelessness that goes with your
scenario is not necessary there's great
hope in your scenario
um but yeah it's fair to over plan and
it's fair to
um
you know have some extras padding
because you might have this probability
because your dad passed early and your
mom did get early onset uh that it just
it just
because of that history you're just
going to be super careful and
that's okay and and
and that's part of personal
financial
it's got personal in it so hey thank you
for your call again i'm just so sorry
for
all the stuff you guys have gone through
and and all the hurt that's been there
for you and because you obviously loved
your mom and dad both and
uh do love them and
and
it's there's
early early onset it's just a man it's
just a beast of a it's just not fair
it's like uh
because we don't know how far it goes we
don't know how long it lasts it's pretty
crazy so um
but i think we can do some statistical
analysis on probabilities and
it's a cold way of looking at it but you
know that this is what you you got to do
this because this is how you figure out
your insurance plans how you figure out
those kinds of things and believe me the
insurance companies are doing these
analysis
so we might as well be in on the math
as you and i america are
planning out our old age
and not losing all the wealth we worked
our whole lives for which is what she's
concerned about and that's a it's a fair
concern
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books our thanks to james charles
and kelly daniel in the booth i am dave
ramsey your host we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily
with the prince of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you